después de las erecciones de medio
terminó el debate político en Estados
Unidos ha girado alrededor de dos temas
fundamentales la marea roja republicana
que nunca llegó y las aspiraciones
presidenciales para el año 2024 los
conservadores se quedaron lejos de una
amplia mayoría en la cámara baja y no
pudieron quitarle el senado a la bancada
demócrata ese panorama Aunque aumenta la
ventaja republicana no están favorable
como esperaba el ex presidente Donald
Trump para lanzar una nueva candidatura
tras perder la reelección contra Joe
biden hace poco más de dos años pero que
le fallaron Por qué le fallaron los
cálculos entonces a los republicanos
sobre todo al líder de ese partido
visiblemente ahora el ex presidente
Donald Trump pues se lo vamos a
preguntar y vamos a analizar este tema
con Fernando tormos aponte el
escenalista político y profesor de
sociología en la universidad de
Pittsburgh gracias
doctor Fernando por estar con nosotros
en directo América de Francia 24 sin
sorpresa Entonces hasta el momento
Donald Trump ya anunció sus intenciones
de ir por la Casa Blanca en el año 2024
considera que este es un anuncio
prematuro porque siente una trama que
esta necesidad de lanzarse a anunciar su
intención de hacerlo tan temprano no
cuando falta Pues un año para estas
elecciones más de un año
bueno ciertamente han surgido una serie
de preguntas sobre su capacidad de
seguir al mando del partido republicano
la elección de medio término ha mostrado
que los endosos de Donald Trump no son
no tienen el valor que Donald Trump
hubiese deseado y bueno muchas personas
plantean que esta medida de tratar de
lanzarse nuevamente era de esperarse
pero que también es una manera de tratar
de dar la impresión que seguir
investigandolo seguir atacandolo de
parte de los demócratas se puede ver muy
mal porque lo ven como lo verían como un
contrincante en una futuras elecciones
claro y estas elecciones de medio
término que ocurrieron ahora en
noviembre es un termómetro digamos o
para ambos partidos tanto el partido de
gobierno en este caso el partido
demócrata y el partido de oposición que
sería el día de hoy el partido
republicano Entonces digamos tras estas
elecciones eh de medio término contará
el ex presidente Donald Trump con los
apoyos necesarios dentro de su partido
para una posible nominación formal para
que sea el candidato único del partido
republicano para correr a la presidencia
en 2024 y digamos que tan debilitado que
otro tras estas elecciones
pues eso está por verse una de las cosas
que hizo Donald Trump cuando estaba
bajo su presidencia fue que el consolidó
lo que era la campaña de Donald Trump
con el partido republicano O sea que él
mantiene un poder enorme sobre el
partido republicano y las finanzas
dentro del partido muchos delegados que
van a las convenciones O sea que el
partido independientemente de si el
electorado a gran escala entiende que
Donald Trump es una persona que debería
aspirar a este a este puesto es el
partido está bajo su control y quienes
atentan cambiar esa realidad la se ven
en una minoría dentro de ese partido y
es o sea tendrán una un reto enorme en
tratar de subvertir el liderazgo de
Trump dentro del partido republicano se
habla también de dos figuras para
digamos o competir con el ex presidente
Donald Trump repartidor republicano ron
de santis el gobernador de la Florida y
también el que fuera el vicepresidente
de Donald Trump Mike pence que tantas
posibilidades reales tendrían ellos para
competir con un rival tan fuerte como el
ex presidente Trump
Yo creo que el reto más grande es que no
gozan de La Maquinaria del partido como
tal Y también una de las cosas que el
Donald Trump hizo en la pasada elección
es que hay que hay que notar que Donald
Trump sacó a una base
a votar por el partido republicano que
en el pasado no salía a votar ningún
candidato a republicano ha recibido
tantos votos como Donald Trump Y eso se
vio al Trump no estar en la papeleta en
esta elección de medio término se vio
que los republicanos algunos sectores de
del partido republicano no se veían tan
entusiasmados por salir a votar sectores
aún más extremos que quizás no no estén
tan entusiasmados por una candidatura de
ron de santis o de Rick Scott o de otros
que podrían retar la cantidad de ruptura
de Trump O sea que sin una maquinaria de
partido como el partido republicano que
es muy importante en los Estados Unidos
sin el poder de esos sectores más
extremos del partido que ayudaron a a
tener un una participación electoral que
pudo haber retado a vaiden se les hará
muy difícil pero estará por verse porque
parece que hay ánimos dentro del partido
y también entre quienes proveen finanzas
verdad y donaciones ha partido de
cambiar el liderazgo del partido O sea
que parece que se van a armar un
contraataque a Trump dentro del mismo
partido y en los próximos meses el
partido se va a ver muy dividido van a
ver unos ataques visibles entre estos
dos sectores claro Fernando también en
estas elecciones de medio término
digamos se pudo ver que fue más fuerte
el rechazo a las políticas republicanas
conservadoras como la restricción al
aborto y la migración más allá no del
cansancio por por todas las situaciones
económica por la inflación del país
porque esto
en los Estados Unidos hay un un aprecio
por los derechos individuales
y el derecho a decidir
en cuanto a los derechos reproductivos
goza de una de un apoyo mayoritario en
los Estados Unidos que No necesariamente
se alberga dentro del partido demócrata
Y eso se vio en en estas elecciones de
medio términos muchas personas salieron
a votar para defender ese derecho no
solo por candidatos que creen en los
derechos reproductivos sino que también
en medidas que apoyaban el derecho
reproductivo y que lo elevaban a
categorías constitucional a niveles de
los estados de los Estados Unidos para
proteger ese derecho o sea que se ha
dado un movimiento de base para apoyar
esos derechos y eso también
de diferentes sectores que se movilizan
a favor del ambiente a favor de los
Derechos civiles y una maquinaria que se
construye para retar a Trump que
permanece activa en los Estados Unidos y
que la han podido movilizar en este
instante de medio término